VIDEOS, JOINS US IN JUST A
MOMENT TO DESCRIBE WHAT HE SAW
TODAY, BUT FIRST, WE WANT TO
BRING YOU SOME YOU KNOW WELL,
BRIAN KILMEADE, SEASON FIVE OF
HIS FOX NEWS SERIES, WHAT MADE
AMERICA GREAT DEBUTS THIS
SUNDAY.
AN EPISODE, WILL SPEAK TO THE
PRESIDENT ABOUT ATTACKS ON OUR
COUNTRY’S MONUMENTS.
HERE’S HOW THE PRESIDENT
RESPONDED.
>> THEY WOULD KNOCK DOWN
LINCOLN, HAVEN’T FIGURED OUT
EXACTLY WHY YET.
GEORGE WASHINGTON,
THOMAS JEFFERSON.
I’VE STOPPED THEM TWICE NOW FROM
GOING OVER TO THE JEFFERSON
MEMORIAL.
THEY WOULD HAVE -- THEY WOULD
KNOCK DOWN THE JEFFERSON
MEMORIAL.
>> Tucker: JUST HOURS AFTER
THAT WAS RECORDED, THEY TRY TO
KNOCK DOWN THAT STATUE AND WERE
PREVENTED FROM DOING THAT.
BRIAN KILMEADE JOINS US TONIGHT,
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
BEFORE I ASK WHY NO ONE IS DOING
ANYTHING ABOUT THIS, WHAT IS THE
POINT OF IT?
WHY STATUES?
WHAT MESSAGE ARE THEY SENDING TO
THE REST OF US?
>> TO TO SHOW YOU HOW NEWSWORTHY
THIS IS, SOMETIMES YOU LOOK AT
WHAT MADE AMERICA GREAT AND YOU
LOOK BACK AT THE PAST, I WAS IN
THE OVAL OFFICE DOING A HISTORY
OF THE WHITE HOUSE WANTED TO GET
HIM TO TALK ABOUT HISTORY AND
THE SAID HE SEGUED RIGHT OVER
THE STATUES, THEY TRY TO DESTROY
OUR HISTORY.
I BROUGHT UP ANDREW JACKSON
BECAUSE THEY ARE TRYING TO TAKE
DOWN JACKSON STATUE IN
NEW ORLEANS.
I TURN ON YOUR SHOW, AND HE
COMMENTED ON THAT.
I TURN ON YOUR SHOW, AND YOU
OPEN LAST NIGHT WITH JUST A
HALF-MILE AWAY TWO HOURS FROM
WHEN I LEFT HIM, TRYING TO TAKE
AWAY ANDREW JACKSON.
BY THE TIME HE WERE OFF THE AIR,
I THOUGHT THAT STATUE WOULD BE
DOWN.
THANKFULLY, THE POLICE GOT
THERE.
I DON’T KNOW WHAT TOOK THEM SO
LONG AND TRYING TO FIND FAULT
WITH OUR PAST BECAUSE THEY DON’T
LIKE THE COUNTRY.
THESE PEOPLE AREN’T TRYING TO
MAKE OUR COUNTRY BETTER.
YOU WANT TO MAKE OUR COUNTRY
BETTER, ANDREW JACKSON HAD.
AS GREAT AS HE WAS, JAILED IN
THE REVOLUTIONARY WAR, ARE YOU
FIGHTING FOR THE COUNTRY AT THE
AGE OF 14?
ALSO, WHEN YOU LOST YOUR FAMILY
TO THE BRITISH, DID YOU PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO YOUR COUNTRY AND
BECOME A LAWYER, AN ATTORNEY
GENERAL, A JUDGE, A CONGRESSMAN,
A MAJOR GENERAL TO WIN THE MOST
DECISIVE, IMPACTFUL BATTLE IN
OUR HISTORY TO THAT POINT IN THE
BATTLE OF NEW ORLEANS AND THEN
GO WANT TO BE A TWO-TERM
PRESIDENT?
THIS IS AN AMERICAN SUCCESS
STORY.
YOU WANT TO PUT AMERICA BETTER,
PUT A PLAQUE ON THERE AND SAY HE
HAD IN HIS DAY AND HE WAS PART
OF THE INDIAN REMOVAL ACT AND
THOSE WEREN’T POSITIVE THINGS
BUT THERE WAS A GENERATION, THE
JACKSONIAN ERA.
THAT’S WHY THERE’S A STATUE.
HE DON’T WANT TO MAKE AMERICA
BETTER.
YOU WANT TO DESTROY OUR PAST
BECAUSE IT DOESN’T LIVE UP TO
THE LOFTY STANDARDS OF THE
SHIRTLESS SKATEBOARDERS WHO WANT
TO PETITION AND PROTEST AND TRY
TO INTIMIDATE REPORTERS ON A
NIGHTLY BASIS.
>> Tucker: THEY HAVE THE
LOWEST STANDARDS THAT I HAVE
SEEN IN ANY GROUP.
TOTALLY IGNORANT, ILLITERATE
VANDALS, AND OUR LEADERS WITH
VERY FEW EXCEPTIONS HAVE DECIDED
TO LET THEM RAMPAGED THROUGH OUR
COUNTRY, AND I DON’T UNDERSTAND
WHY, DO YOU?
>> NO, I DON’T, AND IT MAKES NO
SENSE.
THESE GUYS LIKE TOM COTTON WHO
STAND FOR THOSE IVY LEAGUE
SCHOOLS, BLEEDS RED, WHITE, AND
BLUE AND THERE’S PROBABLY FIVE
OR SIX IN THE SENATE, NOT ONE
DEMOCRAT.
BY THE WAY, HE WAS THE FIRST
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENT.
TO STAND UP FOR HIM.
WHY AM I STANDING UP FOR HIM?
WHY IS TOM COTTON STANDING UP
FOR HIM?
HE MENTIONED FDR.
THEY NEVER TOLD US THE PEOPLE IN
OUR SOCIAL STUDIES BOOKS WERE
PERFECT.
THEY TOLD US THEY WERE IMPORTANT
TO THE MAKEUP OF AMERICA.
AMERICA GETS BETTER AND BETTER
AND BETTER.
WE NEVER SAID WE ARE PERFECT.
WHAT’S GREAT ABOUT US AS WE TRY
TO BE AND THAT’S WHAT JACKSON
WANTS, JACKSON WAS AN EVERYMAN.
HE WASN’T A FOUNDING FATHER, HE
HAD NO CONNECTIONS TO
WASHINGTON, THEY HATED HIM.
THEY TOLD HIM NOT TO GO SO HIS
FAMILY COULDN’T TRUST ANYONE.
WHEN WASHINGTON REJECTED HIM, HE
PUT HIS CASE TO THE PEOPLE.
WHEN HE LOST A CLOSE ELECTION,
HE SHOOK HIS HAND AND
ESSENTIALLY SAID A REMATCH.
HE BEAT HIM FOUR YEARS LATER.
HE WAS THE EVERYMAN PRESIDENT.
SOUTH CAROLINA TRIED TO SECEDE,
HE TOLD SOUTH CAROLINA, HE KEPT
OUR COUNTRY TOGETHER ANOTHER 30
YEARS.
GET A PhD, DON’T TAKE DOWN A
STATUE, I’M SO GLAD THEY MADE
THE STATUE AS TOUGH AS THE
PERSON BECAUSE THEY COULDN’T GET
HIM DOWN WITH CHAINS, COULDN’T
GET HIM DOWN WITH THE ROPES.
THEY CAN DEFILE HIM, BUT
COULDN’T TAKE HIM DOWN.
I’M NOT SAYING I WANT TO BE
ANDREW JACKSON, I’M TELLING YOU
IF I WAS SUFFERING FROM
DYSENTERY AND I HAD TO LEAD AN
ARMY OF RAGTAG AMERICANS,
CHOCTAW INDIANS, REGULAR
MARINES, PIRATES, PUT THEM
TOGETHER, AND THREE WEEKS AND
BEAT AN ARMY THAT JUST BE
NAPOLEON AND WIPE THEM OUT IN 45
PRETTY SPECIAL AMERICAN THAT
DESERVES A STATUE, DESERVES A
PLAQUE, DESERVES YOUR RESPECT.
THAT IS ALL, BE RESPECTFUL OF
OUR PAST.
>> Tucker: MAKE SURE TO CHECK